pancho bienvenido a deportes domingo
finalmente senegal se hizo con la
victoria la primera copa africana en
toda su historia cuáles son las claves
de esta selección para lograr este
triunfo
bueno senegal
ha ganado la tercera final que le tocó
disputar las dos anteriores las había
perdido en 2002 por penales con camerún
y la última en 2019 ante argelia por 1 a
0 pero creo que las claves han estado en
mantener un equipo de trabajo con a liu
si se el entrenador a la cabeza un
entrenador que ya hace varios años que
está al mando de los leones de teranga
que los clasificó en 2018 al mundial de
rusia y que en 2019 en egipto se les
escapó la can pero bueno ahora tuvieron
revancha un equipo que tiene ensayo
maneja su gran figura pero que tiene una
base de jugadores en europa con edward
mendi en el arco con cool y bali y djaló
enlazada central con gana game en el
mediocampo entonces creo que es un
premio merecido esta primera campana
senegal
una final que se preveía ya pareja con
este estilo de juego de un egipto por
ahí más
esperando para salir de contra con sal a
las de las últimas diez finales todas se
definen o bien por penales o bien por
diferencias de 1 a 0 1 a 0 o 2 a 1 así
que bueno senegal no lo pudo liquidar en
los 90 minutos ni en el suplementario
pero finalmente en los penales esa de
humanes se pudo tomar revancha y le dio
el título a su país por primera vez
perfecto pancho y antes de esta final
hemos visto un torneo muy accidentado
con selecciones como argelia que cayeron
en rondas tempranas que casos han sido
los más destacados en esta con 2022
bueno esta es la segunda can que se
juega con 24 países participantes
ya en egipto hubo 24
y por ahí se preveía que este aumento de
equipos a que el nivel de la copa baje
pero bueno ha dado posibilidades a
países no tan tradicionales en lo que es
el ámbito africano como madagascar en
2019 y en esta edición creo que las
grandes revelaciones fueron islas
comoras y gambia que en sus
participaciones debut llegaron a octavos
sí a cuartos de final respectivamente
guinea ecuatorial también que escaló
hasta hasta cuartos de final cosa que ya
había hecho pero esta es la primera
fuera de su país y bueno son países que
no son tan tradicionales en el
continente pero esto hace al fútbol
africano más parejo y hace que por ahí
países tan tradicionales como ghana o
argelia se queden en instancias que por
ahí no se preveía pero bueno tendrán que
mejorar y saber que ya no se gana sólo
con el color de la camiseta o con el
nombre del jugador un cambio desde luego
para el fútbol africano y para acabar
este próximo mes hay eliminatorias
africanas de cara al mundial de qatar
que podemos esperar de estas selecciones
en el próximo mundial
bueno quedan 5 cupos africanos por
definir qué son los cupos que tiene el
continente para el mundial de qatar
serán cinco series creo son muy parejas
x2
también tenemos un clásico de el áfrica
occidental como será ghana nigeria
camerún argelia república democrática
del congo marruecos y mal y túnez así
que bueno se prevé en series muy parejas
hay de vuelta y creo y considero que
cualquiera de los países que vayan a
representar a áfrica lo harán de la
mejor manera y buscarán por primera vez
que el continente tenga un equipo más
allá de semifinales ya que cuartos de
final con camerún en el 90 senegal en
2002 y gana en 2010 es lo máximo que ha
llegado un representativo de áfrica en
la historia de los mundiales